welcome to shop show hot takes brought
to you by rain body fuel this week's hot
take
is coming from the shob show because we
went in
the guy chris pratt decided to take a
little dig at the
reigning middleweight champion of the
world izzy i take too kindly to it so
check out this week's hot take it's a
good one enjoy
and to me this shows you how
dominant of a champion izzy has been
now was that main event a bit of a
snooze fest yeah i'll give you that
my
my issue is not with izzy izzy's the
champ jeer countenaire wants what is he
has it's up to him to make the fight
now there are other champions who show
out put it on the line every time sure
but when you look at the reigning champs
you look at the reigning the guys who
constantly defend the title making big
boy money because the only way to make
big boy money in the ufc is become
multiple defending champion that's when
you get pay-per-view points that's when
the endorsements are coming whether it's
a head kick knockout or a five-round
boring decision it doesn't matter your
money's rolling in and izzy knows this
and izzy's legacy knows this so is he
goes all right
he has to bring the fight to me now if
they don't bring the fight you get a yo
romero fight you get you know these
decisions you get the jared cannon air
fights
it's on them and i would assume jared
cannon is watching the tape this morning
going [ __ ] it was my one shot
it's my one shot i played it safe
because i didn't want to get the
highlight reeled knockout i was playing
it safe i took ready
zero chances in 25 minutes against izzy
otasanya i took
zero [ __ ] chances to win that fight
i guess the feathering cap is i lasted
five rounds with the best middleweight
in the world of all time
yeah that's what you're going for took
zero chances look at the guys that take
chance against izzy look what happened
to him robert whitaker destroyed paulo
casa destroyed kelvin gassim
top three i'd say top two middleweight
fights of all time if you take a chance
against izzy you get a phenomenal fight
if you play it safe he's like this money
in the bank for me dude i'm in cruise
control i'm in the hov lane you suckers
got to get me out of this hov lane
i'm cruising man i'm making all the
money i'm getting all the endorsements
i'm on all the [ __ ] promotional stuff
you want to take this away from me you
want to take away my records my title
make me
to me i don't have a problem with is he
doing this
and i know what's named pratt [ __ ]
the guy and chris chris pratt was like
for me uh i'm disappointed because
uh you know if you talk all that [ __ ]
you gotta show out you gotta do
hey bro
we're not telling you how to make
[ __ ] what's it what movie is he in
jurassic park don't get me started
jurassic park that thing we knew was a
nightmare what was the other thing he's
on
um what is that what's the most famous
one he's guardians of guardians of the
galaxy that's like izzy
criticizing guns and galaxy going ah i
think gru talks too much
probably like what the [ __ ] do you know
about movies this is like nothing at all
so he'd be like
hold on this is the first time you're on
a national broadcast for the ufc and you
take this opportunity to clown our boy
izzy
that's like me yeah he was on the ufc
post show clowning izzy going listen i'm
just an actor
so he knew he was going down that road
they always do that but i'm just acting
but izzy blah blah blah and i heard now
rogan swears by chris pratt says he's a
great guy i actually enjoy chris pratt i
like chris pratt he's a lot of hate
online i don't get it but here's the
thing i'm not a fan
lackluster over jeer cannon there
pitter-patter performance all that talk
pitter-patter
peter pat no pitter patter is called
acting sir pitter-patter would be acting
because none of it's real is it
you don't really have a
best friend that's a raccoon that talks
to you do you you don't have a tree
stump named gru that's basically vin
diesel do you that's pitter patter
is he putting his
freaking health on the line to fight
this monster in jail cannon air and
jared taking zero shots that's his issue
not izzy's izzy makes the same money
dear canada wants what izzy has and
didn't do anything to sacrifice to get
that so what are you gonna do
is i hate on izzy
you get the guy from [ __ ] jurassic
park hate on is he
the guy who's running on a motorcycle
run away from t-rex's hate on izzy
that's what we do these days
pitter-patter dude here's the thing
about those dinosaurs kids you know
t-rex can't run that fast right
did you know that you know they were
slow as [ __ ]
you know anybody in this room could
outrun a t-rex as why because they're
the size of the titanic they're slow as
[ __ ] they're not that scary you know in
the their main thing where they go
that's also fake they think they were
high pitched didn't yell that loud and
also covered in feathers
okay
on those velociraptors that always cause
problems jurassic park you know the size
of a [ __ ] poodle
that's pitter patter dude how dare you
criticize izzy how
dare you love your movies i am a fan i
don't think you should get all the hate
you get i am a fan but you can't come to
the ufc for the first time get on the
mic and hate on our guy we can't have
that dude
we just simply can't have that do you
want me to give you a hot take on
jurassic park i'll tell you when i knew
it was [ __ ] when there's dinosaurs in
the city that's when i'm out if it's
around trees i'm in if you're around
buildings i'm out it's pretty simple
dude
and pterodactyls would be a [ __ ]
nightmare in the city you want to make a
horror movie pterodactyl horror movie
i'm in on that that sounds cool
but these little dinosaurs run around
the city and and i apparently in
jurassic park the new one it's like
humans and [ __ ] dinosaurs get along
i'm out dude
unless it's ice age with her cartoons
i'm not watching it
that's pitter patter sir that's what
that is how dare you come on our
broadcast that you are our ufc post
fight broadcast and the first thing on
your mouth is you hate on the main event
jesus you know what sir you won't be
invited back
unless joe rogan gives you tickets daddy
but you probably will so you'll be back
but god damn he and all this hey dude
and then you hate on izzy
that is weird that of all people chris
pratt would say that it's so strange to
me now everyone has their opinion that
right twitter thinks they're geniuses
and instagram thinks they're geniuses
they want to criticize izzy
you guys don't realize
if izzy were to lose and take chance
against guy like jared cannonaire the
what the the ripple effect it has on his
legacy his career and also his bank
account and his family's bank account
so it's not up to him to risk it all
against guy like jared cannon there